lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
mirar algunos ejemplos de información
representada en diferentes formas y
pensar en cuál representación es la
mejor o la que más nos puede ayudar a
responder ciertas preguntas entonces
veamos este primer ejemplo dice un
especialista en estadística registró la
duración de las primeras 14 películas de
pixar el especialista hizo una gráfica
de puntos cada punto es una película un
historia y un diagrama de caja para
mostrar los datos sobre las duraciones
cuál de las tres gráficas podría usarse
para encontrar la mediana muy bien así
que veamos las tablas aquí vemos la
gráfica de puntos y tenemos un punto
para cada una de las 14 películas
entonces aquí se nos dice que una
película tuvo una duración de 81 minutos
otra duró 92 minutos otra 93 otro duró
95 dos duraron 96 y así se sigue
entonces bueno yo afirmo que yo podría
usar esta información para encontrar la
mediana porque porque esta gráfica de
puntos me puede ayudar a hacer una lista
de todas las duraciones de las películas
podría yo ordenar esa lista y podría
encontrar la mediana entonces yo podría
hacer una lista podría escribir 81 92 93
95 96 2 veces 98 100 y así hacer
realista entonces yo podría escribir
toda la lista y podría encontrar el
valor del medio entonces con la gráfica
de puntos yo creo que si podríamos
encontrar la mediana vamos a dar clic en
esa en esa opción dice elige todas las
opciones correctas y la gráfica de
puntos me parece una buena una buena
opción para encontrar la mediana ahora
veamos el histograma muy bien entonces
aquí está el histograma y ahora la clave
para hallar la mediana es simplemente
hacer una lista de los números y ver
cuál es el valor del medio
y no queda muy claro porque observa aquí
se nos está diciendo que hay una
película que tuvo una duración entre 80
y 85 minutos pero no no nos dice con
exactitud cuánto duró la película bien
pudo ser 81 minutos o tal vez 84 no
sabemos entonces yo aquí no puedo con
esta información yo no puedo hacer una
lista de la duración de las películas y
encontrar la mediana
entonces el histograma no es una buena
opción no le daré clic a esa opción del
histograma ahora veamos el diagrama de
caja aquí está el diagrama de caja ahora
puedes ver qué tal vez no pueda yo hacer
una lista de todas las duraciones de las
películas pero el diagrama de caja
explícitamente nos dice cuál es la
mediana nos está indicando aquí cuál es
la mediana entonces vemos que esto es
100 así que la mediana es 99 esto es 95
96 97 98 99 por lo tanto la mediana es
a grama de caja explícitamente nos dice
cuál es la mediana de hecho es la manera
más sencilla de calcular la mediana así
que doy clic en esta opción esa es una
opción correcta entonces la gráfica de
puntos y el diagrama de caja me sirven
para encontrar la mediana pero el
histograma no muy bien vamos a ver
veamos si estamos en lo correcto
muy bien correcto hagamos otro ejercicio
así que veamos este ejemplo dice leo es
dueño de un albergue y contó el número
de huéspedes que se quedan en cada
habitación creó una historia y un
diagrama de puntos para mostrar los
datos ambos diagramas se muestran a
continuación cuál puede usarse para
encontrar el máximo número de huéspedes
en una habitación el histograma o la
gráfica de puntos veamos entonces
queremos encontrar el máximo número de
huéspedes en una habitación analicemos
el histograma aquí está el histograma
entonces qué nos dice este histograma
aquí tenemos en este en este eje el
número de habitaciones del hostal y
tenemos el número de clientes que hay en
cada una de esas habitaciones entonces
tenemos que hay tres habitaciones que
tienen entre cero y tres huéspedes hay
cinco habitaciones que tienen entre
cuatro y siete huéspedes y nosotros
queremos encontrar el máximo número de
huéspedes en una habitación
entonces el máximo número de huéspedes
que puede haber en una habitación es 23
pero aquí no es explícito este historia
porque observa nos dice que hay una
habitación en la que puede haber entre
20 a 23 huéspedes durmiendo en ella
entonces no es explícito así que el
histograma no nos sirve para encontrar
el máximo número de huéspedes en una
habitación veamos y veamos si la gráfica
de puntos nos ayuda a encontrar esa
respuesta aquí está la gráfica de puntos
muy bien dice número de huéspedes en
cada habitación y aquí podemos ver que
hay dos habitaciones con cero huéspedes
hay una habitación con tres huéspedes
queremos encontrar el máximo número de
huéspedes en una habitación y aquí nos
dice perfecto hay una habitación con 22
huéspedes que es el número máximo de
huéspedes en una habitación así que el
diagrama de puntos si nos sirvió para
encontrar esa respuesta
entonces
el histograma no pero la gráfica de
puntos sí
ahora dice cual deja claro que no hay
habitaciones con un huésped bueno
nuevamente veamos el histograma aquí en
el histograma no sabemos por qué por
ejemplo tenemos que hay tres
habitaciones en las que hay de 0 a 3
huéspedes
entonces aquí no está siendo explícito
así que veamos la gráfica de puntos
dice número de huéspedes en cada
habitación entonces no hay una
habitación que tenga un solo huésped así
que una vez más la gráfica de puntos
salva nuestro día y en ella tenemos la
respuesta que buscábamos entonces cuál
deja claro que no hay habitaciones con
un huésped la gráfica de puntos
vamos a revisar perfecto